ABOUT GIVING UP NUKES.
WE'LL TELL YOU HOW PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS RESPONDING.
ALL HAPPENING IN THE BREAKING
NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
TONIGHT WE HAVE A NEW EXAMPLE OF
JUST HOW DESPICABLY LOW THE HATE
TRUMP MEDIA WILL GO AT EVERY
COST TO TRY TO DAMAGE THIS
PRESIDENT.
THE CORRUPT AND ABUSIVELY
BIASSED PRESS IS EXPLOITING
FORMER ADVISER SAM NUNBERG TO
HELP DO THEIR DIRTY WORK.
NEVER MIND THE FALL THAT SAM
NUNBERG WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
BREAK DOWN AFTER GETTING
SUBPOENAED BY ROBERT MUELLER.
THE MEDIA DIDN'T CARE ABOUT
THAT.
THEY CHEERED HIM ON BECAUSE HE
WAS ATTACKING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DURING A SERIES
OF WHAT ARE REALLY INCOHERENT
INTERVIEWS.
WATCH THE EXPLOITATION.
>> WHY DO I HAVE TO GIVE THEM MY
PERSONAL COMMUNICATIONS?
STEVE BANNON, ROGER STONE?
ROGER IS MY MENTOR.
I E-MAILED ARI WITH ROGER 15
TIMES A DAY.
FOR SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS TO
START CRITICIZING ME AND I KNOW
YOU MAY NOT LIKE IT THE WAY I
SAY IT, SHUT HER FAT MOUTH.
SARAH SHOULD SHUT UP.
SHE SHOULD SHUT HER MOUTH.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THE
QUESTION.
>> YES.
>> DO YOU UNDERSTAND --
>> AND I'M WARNING HER TO SHUT
HER MOUTH.
A LOT OF PEOPLE MADE ME UPSET.
I DON'T THINK -- HAS THIS BEEN
DONE BEFORE?
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SEND ME TO
JAIL.
MR. MUELLER CAN SEND MANY TO
JAIL AND I'LL LAUGH ABOUT IT.
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE FUNNY IF
THEY ARRESTED ME.
I THINK IT WOULD BE REALLY,
REALLY FUNNY IF THEY WANTED TO
ARREST ME BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO SPEND 80 HOURS TO GO OVER
E-MAILS THAT I HAD WITH STEVE
BANNON AND ROGER STONE.
>> I HAVE SMELLED ALCOHOL ON
YOUR BREATH.
>> WELL, I'VE NOT HAD A DRINK.
>> YOU HAVEN'T HAD A DRINK.
IT'S NOT --
>> NO, MY ANSWER IS NO.
>> NO?
>> NO.
BESIDES MY MEDS.
>> OKAY.
>> ANTI-DEPRESSANTS.
IS THAT OKAY?
>> YOU THINK IF ERIN BURNETT
OVER AT FAKE CNN, IF SHE SMELLED
ALCOHOL ON HIS BREATH, MAYBE SHE
WOULDN'T HAVE PUT HIM ON THE
AIR.
THAT WASN'T THE POINT OF WHAT
THE MEDIA WAS DOING.
THEY DIDN'T CARE THAT HE WAS
MELTING DOWN ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION.
THEY WERE USING HILL AS A TOOL
TO ATTACK THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
DIDN'T MATTER IN 91 -- NUNBERG
WASN'T MAKING ANY SENSE.
THEY USED THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ATTACK THE AND SEIZE ON IT.
THE MAINSTREAM WAS OBSESSING
OVER NUNBERG'S FREAK OUT, THEY
MISSED HUGE DEVELOPMENTS IN
STORIES THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN
COVERING LIKE IRREFUTE
COVERING LIKE IRREFUAB
COVERING LIKE IRREFUABLE
CONCRETE EVIDENCE AGAINST THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
THE LIBERAL MEDIA STOPPED CARING
ABOUT THE TRUTH AND FACT AS LONG
TIME AGO.
WHY THE FACTS FIRST NETWORK,
FAKE CNN, WILL GO ANYWHERE IN
THE WORLD TO TRY TO PROVE THEIR
TRUMP RUSSIAN CONSPIRACY THEORY
TO BE TRUE.
I'M NOT MAKING IT UP.
THIS IS FROM FAKE NEWS CNN.
THEY SENT A REPORTER TO
THAILAND.
WHY?
TO INTERVIEW A JAILED RUSSIAN
PROSTITUTE/SEX COACH WHO IS
CLAIMING TO HAVE INFORMATION
ABOUT 2016 ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
CNN COULDN'T BRING IN A CAMERA
IN THE PRISON, BUT HERE'S WHAT
THEY REPORTED.
DID YOU MISS THIS?
>> I JUST CAME OUT OF THIS
DETENTION CENTER WHERE I SPOKE
WITH A WOMAN.
IT WAS LOUD AND HOT AND CHAOTIC
AND TALKING THROUGH THE BARS,
SHE SAYS THAT SHE WITNESSED
MEETINGS BETWEEN THE RUSSIAN
BILL
BIL
BILLIONAIRES.
SHE WOULDN'T GIVE FURTHER
INFORMATION BECAUSE SHE COULD BE
DEPORTED.
>> Sean: CNN SENDS A REPORT TORE
THAILAND TO TALK TO A RUSSIAN.
IF YOU'RE SURPRISED BY THIS, YOU
SHOULD NOT BE.
CNN LITERALLY WENT DUMPSTER
DIVING LAST MONT IN
ST. PETERSBURG RUSSIA OUTSIDE
THE TROLL FARM THAT TRIED TO
INFLUENCE THE ELECTION.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S LIKE A COMPUTER OR
ELECTRONIC STUFF THAT HAS BEEN
DELIVERED THERE RECENTLY.
WE SAW THEM TAKING OUT THE BOXES
FOR WHAT LOOKS LIKE NEW
COMPUTERS.
>> Tucker: DUMPSTER DIVING, SEX
COACHES, PROSTITUTES.
IF YOU WANT EVIDENCE OF REAL
RUSSIA COLLUSION, YOU DON'T HAVE
TO WASTE YOUR TIME TRAVELING
AROUND THE WORLD AND DIVING IN
DUMPSTERS AND GOING TO JAIL TO
MEET SEX COACHES.
IT'S IN FRONT OF YOUR FACES AND
HAS BEEN OVER A YEAR.
WE ON THIS PROGRAM HAVE BEEN
EXPOSING HOW ALL ROADS IN THIS
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION LEAD
DIRECTLY BACK TO HILLARY
CLINTON.
SHE'S AT THE CENTER OF
EVERYTHING.
YOU HAVE THE CLINTON BOUGHT AND
FADE FOR RUSSIAN DOSSIER, THE
LYING DOSSIER.
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA AND LIES.
JOHN SOLOMON REPORTING THAT THE
AUSTRALIAN DIPLOMAT THAT STARTED
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION, HE
HAS DEEP TIES TO THE CLINTONS,
INVOLVED IN $25 MILLION GOING TO
THE FOUNDATION.
SID VICIOUS BLUMENTHAL, CODY
SHEERER.
THEY WERE FEEDING ANTI-TRUMP
DIRT TO THE OBAMA STATE
DEPARTMENT.
A NEW UPDATE FROM SARAH CARTER.
SHE'S REPORTING THAT THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE IS INVESTIGATING
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE JOHN
KERRY AND HIS ROLE IN THE
DOSSIER.
WE JUST TOLD YOU KERRY'S STATE
DEPARTMENT WERE RECEIVING
ANTI-TRUMP INFORMATION FROM
LONG-TIME CLINTON ALLIES.
INVESTIGATE THAT CNN?
FORMER STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL.
REMEMBER JONATHAN WINTER?
HE MET WITH FORMER BRITISH SPY
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
AND STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL,
VICTORIA NEWLAND?
SHE SAID STEELE GAVE THE STATE
DEPARTMENT PAGES OF INFORMATION
THAT SHE TURNED OVER TO THE FBI.
SO HERE'S THE KEY QUESTIONS.
WHAT DID JOHN KERRY KNOW NOW,
WHEN DID HE KNOW IT AND DID THIS
INFORMATION FROM STEELE AND
CLINTON'S ALLIES MAKE IT TO HIS
DESK?
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
CHAIR, DEVIN NUNES SENT A LIST
OF TEN KEY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
DOSSIER.
BUT IT'S UNCLEAR IF JOHN KERRY
IS ONE OF THEM.
SARAH COURTER WILL REVEAL ALL IN
A REPORT COMING UP IN MOMENTS.
RIGHT NOW, EVEN MORE EVIDENCE
THAT THE FIX WAS IN FOR THE
FBI'S CORRUPT CLINTON E-MAIL
INVESTIGATION.
TONIGHT FOX IS REPORTING THAT
TRUMP PAINTING AGENT PETER
STRZOK WAS TOLD THAT HILLARY
CLINTON'S PRIVATE SERVER MAY
HAVE BEEN HACKED, BUT THEN HE
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
JUST MORE PROOF THE FBI DID NOT
EVER AT ANY POINT CONDUCT A REAL
INVESTIGATION THAT THE FIX WAS
IN AND IT WAS RIGGED FOR HILLARY
CLINTON IN THE BEGINNING.
WE KNOW THAT COMEY AND STRZOK
WERE DRAFTING THE EXONERATION
STATEMENT.
IN THAT LETTER, THEY CHANGED THE
LANGUAGE THAT SAID IT WAS
REASONABLY LIKELY THAT CLINTON'S
SERVER WAS HACKED AND POSSIBLE
THAT THE SERVER WAS ACCESSED BY
HOSTILE FOREIGN ACTORS.
MAYBE RUSSIA.
THINK ABOUT IT.
IT WAS PREVIOUSLY REPORTED THAT
FIVE FOREIGN ACTORS HAD HACKED
CLINTON'S SERVER.
ONE OF THEM PROBABLY HAS TO BE
RUSSIA.
ANOTHER BEING CHINA.
POSSIBLY IRAN.
WAS IT NORTH KOREA?
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE HAD ACCESS
TO TOP SECRET MATERIAL.
THAT MEANS AMERICAN SOURCES AND
METHODS WERE REVEALED, WHICH
MEANS AMERICAN LIVES WERE THEN
PUT IN DANGER.
SO STRZOK PUT HIS PERSONAL
BIASES AHEAD OF PROTECTING
AMERICANS AND AMERICAN NATIONAL
SECURITY WHILE RUSSIA AND OTHERS
WERE LITERALLY LOOKING PAGE BY
PAGE AND STEALING OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY SECRETS.
NOW WHAT STRZOK DID HERE IS
BEYOND A DERELICTION OF DUTY.
IT'S A CRIME, WHICH IS WHY WE
HAVE TO ASK, HOW DOES PETER
STRZOK STILL HAVE A JOB?
BETTER YET, WHY ISN'T HE BEING
INVESTIGATED?
WE NOW HAVE A MOUNTAIN OF
EVIDENCE OF BIAS AND WRONG DOING
AGAINST PETER STRZOK AND SO MANY
OTHERS AND THIS IS NEW
INFORMATION TO ADD TO THE LIST.
SO IT'S TIME TO HOLD HIM
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE ALSO HAVE BREAKING TONIGHT,
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, BOB
GOODLATTE AND TREY GOWDY,
THEY'RE MAKING A JOINT PLEA TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, I'D
LIKE TO JOIN THEM.
REQUESTING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
JEFF SESSIONS, APPOINT A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE
THIS MISCONDUCT, THIS BIAS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND THE FBI.
ACCORDING TO THE REQUEST, A
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL WOULD
INVESTIGATE FISA AND WHY THE
UNVETTED, UNVERIFIED PHONY
STEELE DOSSIER, HOW WAS IT OVER
ABLE TO BE USED TO OBTAIN A
WARRANT AGAINST CARTER PAGE.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
AS WE SAID SO MANY TIMES, A
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS NEEDED.
THEY CAN'T INVESTIGATE
THEMSELVES.
IT'S THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, JEFF
SESSIONS' JOB TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN.
FINALLY TONIGHT, AFTER DECADES
OF INACTION AND SO MUCH
DIPLOMATIC FAILURE THAT RESULTED
IN A NUCLEAR ARMED NORTH KOREA,
A BREAK THROUGH POTENTIALLY IS
ON THE HORIZON.
TALKS BETWEEN NORTH AND SOUTH
KOREA HAVE BEEN PROGRESSING.
OFFICIALS IN PYONGYANG ARE NOW
REPORTEDLY OPEN TO RENEGOTIATING
THE DENUCLEARIZATION IN THE
REGION.
OF COURSE, THE KINGDOM HAS
EXPRESSED AN INTEREST IN
NORMALIZING RELATIONS WITH THE
UNITED STATES, HAS MADE EFFORTS
TO END NUCLEAR BALLISTIC MISSILE
TESTS AND THIS COMES WEEKS AFTER
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ENACTED
TOUGH NEW SANCTIONS AGAINST
NORTH KOREA AND MONTHS SINCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP MOVED A THIRD
CARRIER STRIKE GROUP TO THE
REGION.
HERE'S WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD
TO SAY ABOUT THESE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS EARLIER TODAY.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT NORTH
KOREA'S RECENT WILLINGNESS TO
TALK IS SINCERE OR IS IT AN
EFFORT TO BUY TIME FOR THEIR
NUCLEAR PROGRAM AND WHAT DO YOU
OWE THIS OPENNESS TO TALK?
>> ME.
NO, I THINK THAT -- NOBODY GOT
THAT.
I THINK THAT THEY ARE SINCERE
BUT THEY'RE SINCERE BECAUSE THE
SANCTIONS AND WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH RESPECT TO NORTH KOREA,
ININCLUDING THE GREAT HELP THAT
WE'VE BEEN GIVEN FROM CHINA, AND
THEY CAN DO MORE, BUT THEY HAVE
DONE MORE THAN CERTAINLY THEY
HAVE EVER DONE FOR OUR COUNTRY
BEFORE.
SO CHINA HAS BEEN A BIG HELP.
I THINK THAT'S BEEN A FACTOR.
THE SANCTIONS HAVE BEEN VERY,
VERY STRONG.
VERY BITING.
WE DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN.
SO I REALLY BELIEVE THAT ARE
SINCERE.
I HOPE THEY'RE SINCERE.
WE'LL FIND OUT.
>> Sean: THESE REVELATIONS MAY
HAVE A BREAK THROUGH, IT'S
UNLIKELY THE UNITED STATES WILL